-Welcome back, Jon.
-Ahh!
-You know,
it is your 10th appearance.
-Double dige!
-Double digits!
-I'm so happy!
Double dige! I'm so happy.
-Aww.
-10th appearance.
-That means you like me.
-I love you.
I more than like you.
Please, come on
for another 50 appearances.
-Oh, okay.
-A thousand appearances.
-You have to give me
my beard back.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I kind of am
trying to figure this out.
I'm not sure where it is.
-It looks fantastic.
-Really?
-I'm on board. I'm on --
[ Applause ]
The people have spoken.
-I want to thank you also
for helping me out.
You did an episode of
"Password."
-How much fun did we have?
-We had the best time
in "Password,"
and thank you for doing that.
You came on, and it was
a tribute to Betty White,
that show.
-The best.
-It was our first show.
You did me a solid.
Thank you for that.
Remember, we did a sketch
with Betty White?
-Oh, my God.
-For the Emmys?
-It was a "Glee" parody.
-Yes.
-6B.
-It was
"Studio 6B, a 'Glee' Parody."
-And my job was to
back that thang up.
-Yeah.
Into Betty White's...front.
[ Cheering ]
-She was like a choreographer.
She was like, "Back that
thing up, back that..."
How funny was Betty White?
-She was in her 90s.
-The greatest.
-God bless her.
-God bless Betty White.
She was the greatest.
-My favorite part was,
the continuation of that was
that we had kind of
a quick change after that,
and I had to present
right after that with Betty,
And it was awesome, but I had to
get out of my "Glee" costume,
and into my tuxedo.
So I had to do like,
a quick change backstage,
and Betty was right there.
-In front of Betty?
-Oh, yeah.
-And by the way,
did not look away.
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
Betty White is a legend.
I love that.
-Took it in. She took it in.
-I haven't seen you
since you owned the summer
with the blockbuster,
"Top Gun: Maverick."
No big deal.
-Thank you, thank you.
[ Applause ]
The biggest movie ever made.
Come on, buddy!
-I can't wait till they
re-release it 15 years later,
"Avatar" style.
-Dude, I saw you on
the on the big screen,
but I saw you
on the biggest screen.
Oh, the IMAX? Yeah.
-Yeah.
I loved it.
-It's kind of an experience.
-Dude, your movie was
the greatest thing.
-Did that spontaneously
make you grow that beard?
Watching that, it was just so
testosterone-filled?
-So action-packed, like...
And then, you know,
I saw the movie,
and then I go, and I went
to a great restaurant.
Emilio's Ballato.
-I forgot about this.
-And this is
an Italian restaurant,
opening weekend
of "Top Gun: Maverick,"
and I happen to run into there,
my best bud, Jon Hamm.
-Yes.
-Was there eating dinner
at this restaurant.
-You were two-timing me, though.
You were there with Harry Kane.
-I was there with Harry Kane.
-Talking football, I'm assuming.
-Yeah.
-[In British accent] Football.
-[In British accent]
Yeah, we were talkin' football.
-Let's get some Italian food.
-It's what people like.
You go and you play football,
you get Italian food.
-Some pasta.
-Pasta.
-Maybe some, like,
eggplant parm.
-Your ravioli.
-Whatever. Whatever.
-Whatever.
-Don't even matter.
-Doesn't matter, does it?
-Does it?
-Just buds.
-Does it? Spuds.
-Buds and spuds.
-Oh, buds and spuds.
Exactly right.
[In normal voice]
So I was there cheating on you.
Yeah, with Harry.
Thank God we weren't
sitting together.
We would have done this
all night.
-The whole restaurant
would have left.
-No, but I was happy to see you,
because it was a big --
-Yeah, yeah.
You gave me a nice gift.
That was really sweet of you.
-Do you remember?
-I do, the waiter came over
with a sort of dirty plate
and half a meatball on it
and said, "Mr. Fallon would
like to gift this to you."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I gave you
half of meatball.
-And I ate it.
[ Laughter ]
-Good meatball.
[British accent] Good meatball.
-[British accent] Meatball.
-Great meatball, mate.
-Play football
and great meatball.
Football, meatball.
-Football, meatball.
Half a meatball. Meat-foot.
-Meat-foot..
We...
You know what it is?
I saw you there, and I go,
oh, I don't know
if you recognize me,
so I want to to send him over
something
to congratulate him,
because "Top Gun" was already...
-You weren't in disguise.
-I didn't have a beard then.
-You did not have a beard then.
-But yeah, I guess it is was
a small restaurant.
I guess you did see me,
but didn't want to bother you.
But I thought it'd be funny
to send you over something.
I go, I'll send over a meatball.
That'll make him laugh.
Then I go, no, no, no.
[British accent] Wait, wait.
-[British accent] Wait.
-Wait, come back here.
-Oy.
-Oy! Oy.
Back here.
-Oy, waiter!
-Hey.
-Oy, an old meatball.
-Oh, now, -- now --
[Accent becomes gravely]
No, now I'm turning to Statham.
-[Imitating Jason Statham]
Are you gonna be Jason Statham?
-Jason Statham?
Give him half a meatball.
-Half a meatball.
[ Laughter ]
-Give him the ol' demi-ball.
-Give him the 180.
[In normal voice]
You've already starred in
one of the greatest TV
shows of all time.
-Thank you.
-"Mad Men."
-Oh, that one.
-Yeah.
[ Applause ]
A little hit.
-Pretty good. Pretty good.
Yeah, kind of a home run.
-Had a good run.
Had a good run. A good run.
-But now you're returning to TV
with not one, but two shows.
-Double dip.
-Wow. Double digits, double dip.
-Double dige, double dip.
-Yeah "Fargo."
-Half a meatball, two meatball.
Double dip, who cares?
-"Fargo."
[ Laughter ]
"Fargo" and "The Morning Show."
-"Fargo."
-I like going off
the rails with you.
It's fun. Why not?
Wait, "Fargo."
-"Fargo," it's a fantastic show.
Each season sort of reimagines
the whole story,
although they are kind of --
Rock was on it last year.
It was in Kansas City
in the '30s.
-Chris Rock was on "Fargo."
-Yes, it was great.
It was great
to see him doing all that.
-That's gonna be
a great fit for you.
-So this one does not take place
in Kansas City in the '30s,
but it does sort of,
keeps imagining organized crime
and what's happening.
I play a rather
unsavory character.
-Ooh.
-I can't really get into it.
-Wow. You can't get into it?
-Well, I mean,
I'm gonna very into it.
I can't give deets.
And "The Morning Show."
I get to hang out with Aniston.
-Reese Witherspoon.
-Reese.
-Billy Crudup.
-Billy Cruds.
-Oh, I love that dude.
-Great cast, great people.
I can't really get into it.
[ Laughter ]
-"I can't get into it
right now."
-I'd love to get it.
I just can't.
Oh, I can't get into it.
-"I just can't talk."
Well, I want to talk about this
film, "Confess, Fletch."
-You know I'm a giant
"Fletch" fan.
We've talked about this,
but this is a great story.
-We did it. We actually made it.
It's in theaters and on
digital platforms near you.
-"Confess, Fletch."
-It's the second book
in the series.
When they made that movie
with Chevy Chase,
very famously inaugurated
that film franchise
and put his stamp right on it.
So we were like, "Oh, God.
I don't want to do
a Chevy impression."
-Yeah, of course.
-And I don't want to, you know,
steal his bits.
So we went back to the books,
and there's 11 novels
that Gregory McDonald
wrote over the course
of the '70s and '80s,
and they're really funny
and they're fun.
And we just kind of took it
back to the page.
-But you watched "Fletch"
when it first came out with --
-Oh, my God, did I ever?
I saw it at
the Wehrenberg Theater
in Saint Louis, Missouri.
[ Applause ]
I thought maybe there was
some Wehrenbergs in town.
-Why would that get applause?
We're not in Saint Louis.
-Right? Everybody gets it.
-You saw it in Times Square
in New York City.
[ Applause ]
You'll never forget it.
-Never forget it.
-Never forget going to Times
Square and watching "Fletch."
-When I was 14, somehow.
-Yeah.
-Wildly dangerous,
in the '80s, by myself.
-Yeah, well, you saw it
and you loved it.
-I saw it and loved it.
-But you got into it and you go,
"I'm going to watch this.
I'm obsessed with this movie."
And then you realized that it
was based on based on a book.
And so I was like,
"Wait, there's more?
There's more stories?"
And I immediately went
to the bookstore
and realized I had no money,
so I stole all of the paperbacks
that I could steal.
-How did you steal
11 paperbacks?
-Not at once!
-Oh, alright.
You went back and stole more?
-One at a time.
-Wow.
-Then they don't see.
They don't think
they're missing.
-Do the people
at Walden Books --
-If you take
the whole section out,
the guy's like,
"What are you doing?"
You take one, it's like,
"Hey, what is that over there?
That's weird. Oh, yeah."
-So you stole all
of the "Fletch" books?
-I sure did.
And now I'm gonna steal
the franchise from Chevy.
-Yeah, exactly.
But here you are.
Will you make all 11 movies?
-I hope.
That's up to America
to decide, but...
[ Cheers and applause ]
And all the foreign territories.
But I really hope to.
Obviously, it's set up to be,
you know,
kind of a franchise
in the making.
-How do we describe
"Confess, Fletch"?
-It's a whodunit,
and by the end,
you definitely find out
who done it.
I mean, that delivers
right there on its promise.
-It delivers?
-Yeah.
-But it's a funny, you know...
He talks his way out of trouble
that he's already
talked himself into,
so that's kind of
perfect for me.
-Yeah, it's actually great.
I can't think of a better person
to play Fletch.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here is Jon Hamm in
"Confess, Fletch."
Take a look.
-So what do we know
about this victim?
-Like we're going to tell you.
-Laurel Goodwin's from Westover,
was living in Allstrom
with two roommates, worked at
a Cambridge cafe as a barista.
-We're telling you.
-Ms. Goodwin was pursuing
a career in the art world.
-Hmm.
-Interesting connection.
-Well, I've either just
walked into a frame-up,
or somebody from my past
is trying to get revenge on me.
-Who hates you?
Besides Griz.
-Well, I did put quite a few
prominent people away
when I was
a very famous reporter
at the "News Tribune"
in Los Angeles.
-I looked into
your criminal record.
-And?
-Bad check charge.
-Eh.
-Two contempt of court charges.
-Pfft.
-A number of nonpayment
of alimony charges.
-100% of most of
those were dismissed.
-You're a bit of
a shady character, Mr. Fletcher.
-But I am adorable.
-Yeah! That's right.
Jon Hamm, everybody!
-Heyo!
-"Confess, Fletch."
When we come back, Jon and I
are going head-to-head
in the game of "Hey, Robot."
-Hey, Robot!
-Stick around.